right there's my horizontal axis how far
my gotta go my back lashes now the
highest value I have is 21 but that's
kind of an awkward number right and I
also have to go all these numbers in
between and they're not there is messy
so what I'm going to do is I'm actually
gonna go up to 25
okay 20 flags like a pretty round number
I would have chosen 20 but I've got to
go to pass that okay so if I put 25 RP
on then again this is easy to break up I
just have to break this up into five
portions
yeah
so now that I've decided on my
horizontal and vertical scale that's a
really important step by the way Tony
for it I can now use this to say well
I've got all of these points right here
and I can plot them every column on my
table of values is a point right
remember you've seen coordinates before
things like this one comment through so
this is an independent variable and the
dependent variable it goes with it and
they have hit together so you can see
here my first pair will be one and three
point five so here's one and you can
read up where three point five is going
to be on your graph so let's do this
together I'll encourage you to draw
generally speaking your axes in and your
actual graph this part in here in pencil
there's no like like absolute are
Possible's on it but what I'm drawing on
the paper
I find it quite difficult to do this
accurately I run out some on the last
thing you want to do is that to cover
your actual grab and why that it's a
mess where else didn't have trouble with
drawing accident I think we're pretty
good at this right so that's why I put
that pen put this in pencil make sure
it's quite firm because this is just
fresh in my mind that the HSC they
scared and your papers right and I don't
know if anyone's seen what happens when
you're scared pencil pencils or some
pliers so you've got to make sure it's
quite dark so that it's actually going
to come up on the image okay so you
probably will I've been maybe one or two
steps behind me you've played you know
your points if you have plotted them
accurately
to be able to join them together and
this being linear relationships you
should have a straight line now this is
what my graph looks like I start here
and I end there because this is exactly
the values that I've gone when we got 1
through 6 and that's all of the points
that I've got but then we're going to
use this we're gonna go so conclusion ok
so you can see Part B says use the graph
to find the cost of 2 now to knock us
where is that on your graph get a get a
new color okay and if you see it ok 2.5
should be exactly halfway between them
so there is 2.5 by the way one of the
reasons why we put units over here on
the labels of the axes is so we already
have to put units but every single one
of these numbers so I go to the same
super funky and just say 2.5 and the
kilos come from the axes while I'm gonna
go do is read up from 2.5 so you may
like to get your rule out and roll up
okay now that's what my draws up to
obviously yours will vary a little bit
depending on how accurate you draw this
tells me I'm looking at about something
like $10 ish now i three handed this I
didn't rule it out I didn't measure it
to carefully so I'm not 100% confident
what's up - spices are you guys reading
off your graphs by on lower just over 10
so I've adjusted us adjust though about
yeah I was anywhere yes or do you think
yeah good eye yes very good
okay so when you're being assessed on
these right obviously the accuracy of
your graph will affect how close you is
not being and you can see most fitness
which has been throwing out all the same
bullpup all within like 50 cents to a
dollar of each other and that's fine
right you will often be supplied with a
graph and therefore because it's all
perfect there for you you need to be
able to read that to a reasonable degree
of accuracy but if you build it yourself
there's always you're within a
reasonable range you're okay and we
talked about you know units of
measurement and air off the trigger and
that kind of noise okay so therefore
that was potting and poppy I'm going to
conclude I'm gonna say approximately so
alright
unfortunately in dollars okay that's
what I'm reading off there because some
people have more something lovely now we
find something question that's it but I
just want to push on this little teeny
before just so you can see what's going
on and not just me
answer questions but think it through
okay first thing you remember how I said
I'm grass thought someone I actually
could go further back good night I can
go further to the left if I drew it if
you continue your life where would it go
where would its time on mind my graph
looks like it's going to continue and
it's gonna hit that spot it's a special
spot yeah when when AXYZ may recall that
the origin okay its way you've got zero
of this and zero of that does that make
sense
yeah is that a reasonable - we always do
sense checks right and it is we don't
buy any oranges you don't pay anyway
that's good okay this you go on forever
as well on a push on this just a teeny
bit more right
this is sort of extending into the next
exercise but we actually have used this
and those of you too did some
interesting questions before I've
already kind of this that once I we can
she uses to be precise and to check
whether we do this right if I want to
write an equation that link these two
values together I'm going to write
that's the cost the dependent variable
is going to be the weight and it
multiplied by something right I think
back to all the financial stuff like an
allowance that you get what am i
multiply by the way to get costs price
by the price per kilo I was just 350 so
I think I like this okay now the
question was try to answer in Part B was
what if I bought to the hot Keeler's I
can just subscribe maybe we did this in
am one remember I have to see how the
skills business so if I say 2.5 times
the 300 studio
eight said nothing so this is a contra
great way he slowly started without the
graphs we started with just the numbers
first because they're powerful tools and
they can help you check beginning arrive
I guess my under ten was just met in the
Bible